Mike Pence is having a tough go of it
Mike Pence appeared uh on a radio
program yesterday
and Mike Pence as you may know has not
committed to pardoning Donald Trump if
Trump were to be indicted on any of
these various indictments that he is
facing and possibly future uh
indictments the host didn't like it and
confronted Mike Pence and it actually is
is quite interesting take a listen to
this ultimate decider with all due
respect when you aren't telling us what
your decision would be I think you're
dodging the question and and and frankly
not stepping up on the on the front of
leadership which in the past you've been
willing to do so I I to me not answering
is a no
well look I
number one I don't think you know what
the president's defense is do you
I mean what are the facts I mean look we
either believe in our judicial process
in this country or we don't we
understand
by the rule of law we don't I just uh
what I would tell you is I think as
someone what I'm hearing is you're fine
with Donald Trump being put in prison
sir and that to me since you were his
vice president feels pretty
disrespectful I had a standard rule I
don't talk about hypotheticals but look
we don't know what the president's
defense here is I think he's entitled to
make his defense entitled to have his
day in court and uh look let's you know
let's take it one step at a time but I I
would just tell you that I I uh but if
you know that these are political
charges and you do this is not this is
not a difficult decision I think we've
gotten I think we've gotten what we're
going to get here in terms of an answer
to this one um yeah
I think it's the clay and buck show and
the co-host is like yeah we we probably
should move on I think any conclusion by
anyone running for the presidency of the
United States that would prejudge the
facts in this case or prejudge the
investigation into President Biden or
his family is pretty much sure let's let
let's let the process play out let's
follow the facts and I promise you as
president of the United States I'll do
just that
so you know the bar is extremely low
I want to say to you this is more or
less the right answer but it's only more
or less the right answer once we've
adjusted our expectations and put the
bar really really low around Mike Pence
and case in point
three weeks ago Pence was singing a
different tune when the indictment was
the one out of New York Pence only
recently changed his tune we we reported
this to you yesterday Mike Pence has
sudden change of heart over Trump
classified documents I can't defend it
having read the indictment these are
very serious allegations Pence told the
Wall Street journals editorial board
Tuesday so in one sense Pence is correct
why on Earth would I tell you now I'm
going to Pardon someone when they
haven't even put on a defense they
certainly haven't been convicted we just
don't have enough information the
Counterpoint from the hosts is if you
concede the charges are merely political
in nature then does it really matter
what the defense is wouldn't you be
inclined to say that you're going to
Pardon Donald Trump because the bar is
so low it is 2023 I'm not going to
pretend that we're in the 90s okay or
the late 80s or whenever the bar is so
low that I'm willing to give Pence some
credit for saying to this guy you're not
going to get me to say right now that
I'm going to Pardon Trump the question
that becomes increasingly interesting is
we're seeing a split among Republican
candidates some who say I would
absolutely pardon Trump and others who
say no I wouldn't or at least I can't
commit to that right now that is
becoming a clash between the candidates
and it will be very interesting to see
if that issue comes up in the debates
which will be starting in August one of
our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit few Zoom is an
Innovative award-winning device that
does exactly that fume is not electronic
there's no Vapor or harmful chemicals
fume is just a delicious flavored air
that makes replacing your bad habit easy
your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable Parts which is great for
fidgeting which can be great for people
breaking bad habits look at what people
online are saying they weren't sure what
to expect but ended up loving the taste
and the feel stopping is something lots
of people put off because it's difficult
to do but switching to fume is easy and
enjoyable there's no reason that you
can't be the next fume success story
head on over to trifum.com and use the
code Pacman to save 10 when you get the
journey pack which comes with the device
and three flavors the link is down below